we go with him everybody to another
league of legends live stream happy
Friday we're hoping to continue our
streak of two games in a row that's akin
to three like the street yeah it's the
world record streak we're on here this
run is unprecedented except what we did
before and it was longer but we started
from we said yeah and we're gonna we're
out wearing the middle of a new
unprecedented run all right well I think
we all got a case of rishis giggles
today or something here where we're
excited um my usual co-host Rishi kept
in the house what's up Rishi hey guys
happy friday happy to be here as always
and a cup of love I love it and junior
eyes is in the house and in the game
with me we're queuing up are we queuing
up oh there we go we are queuing up all
right I'm trying to play jungle jrs
trying to play mid we'll see what
happens uh Rishi has couple of today I
love that yeah I got a couple up are you
asking me how my cup of water would that
it no let us a better question Justice
tape oh hey yeah what are you drinking
what do we what are we having today well
we've got our Duncan version of pumpkin
spice latte is it good oh yeah I guess
it's like our just like our losing
streak a little bit I've kind of had
like some losing streaks with the coffee
that I've been testing so I know we're
going to we're going to get back in the
game now all right I well I like that
guy I like that you consider yourself
part of the the team on how we play like
if Jay and I lose at least I'm feeling
the love and I'm at j educated me on the
pumpkin spice latte apparently it's a
starbucks invention and so the first one
he brought me was from tim moore
which is kind of like a dunkin donuts uh
like price point wise experience was
kind of like a donut but then he brought
me the starbucks one and you can see the
difference so I I like bone all right
you can tell the difference but I'm also
not the coffee like you know I wouldn't
want to bring Rishi the wrong cup of
coffee let me say that well you know
already went to get me because you and
your mom and I like the same brand a lot
so nice you can you can always associate
that brand with me if you ever have to
out all right I like it I like it I like
it well I'm drinking my new nettle tea
the J reyez brought along in my believe
mug my honey nettle tea so we're back
leg yeah I need I need I feel like I'm
missing this quote of the day thing i
wanna i wanna i gotta get the other no
no to you did the other little t have a
court of the day so until we reach
started okay that's where it started
okay yes this is a new brand of nettle
tea that doesn't have the quote on it
coolness nettle tea maybe that's the
code just there is no closer silence so
just a moment of silence for the middle
tea okay good well as ever since you
made that ever since you made that
comment about the pumpkin spice latte I
I have a whole new I'm looking at the
picture of the founder behind your
shoulder and I'm thinking is he did
approve him if you disapprove about my
comment no it's just like I see him
looking over your shoulder right it
isn't that the founder of the starbucks
are like right now here I told ya yep so
it's like a be careful here bad but
pumpkin fight loudly what I gave it lots
of love the starbucks pumpkin spice that
was it was the it was the best it was
the original no no absolutely
saying like it's just funny i'm just
looking at the pictures we're talking so
I'm like be careful when you say he's
laughing you know their their head
office in Canada is right across the
street from China dance salsa really
yeah so sometimes their staff were like
bow ties and dress up a little bit
because this because it's the heart
office so their head offices on the
whatever like it's an office tower and
they're on the top floor or whatever
somewhere in that building and on the
ground floor is an actual starbucks
location so you can go and have coffee
there so I I'll often go you know when
I'm itds I have you know I'll walk
across the street get a starbucks and
then you know maybe how it's here say hi
second conversation if he was going to
be anywhere in Canada you know if he's
stopping here that's where he's gonna be
so yeah get him on the channel bring him
back here Howard Howie Howie look at
your attitude live stream awesome
alright well that's been tons of banter
when we get questions all right let's do
it where we got it okay first question
is coming from chiku she could says of
the people i know i'm thinking you're
the one who might understand my dilemma
I'm in a situation I have been offered a
consultant opportunity partnering with a
very large organization I will be
involved in capacity building for the
community I woke up one day with an idea
in my head and call this organization I
thought about it for four months they
agreed to see me and I've had two
meetings with them already my worry is I
don't know what I'm doing the partners
seemed interested in what I had to share
and have asked if I could tell them
about my entity but I'm not an
organization i'm just an individual
slugging it alone with an idea inside my
head I've had two weeks to do a short
presentation before the board I have two
weeks before if this idea works i'll be
in a position to change lives of
hundreds of people in their family
he's been reading her blog for two years
your newsletter and then he basically
says back to the dilemma I feel like a
fraud what do i do I requested the
meeting I didn't think anyone would take
me seriously they did and now i'm
running for the hill I've never been
this intimidated by my potential all
right wow this is really cool there's a
lot of things about this that I think
are very teachable number one just like
the power of betting on yourself it
sounds like he had enough confidence
dude take the first step and looks like
i don't know the outcome of this
situation but sounds like some doors
started opening and I i just i did a
video once on my channel just about like
what doors are you afraid to walk
through you know what open doors are you
afraid to walk through because what
don't think any of us what we need a
difference I like that yeah because
we're so afraid of failure but then I
mean we all know what it is to feel
afraid of actually succeeding and like
he says being intimidated by his
potential and so there's a whole beer at
least I've experienced around walking
through when the doors do open and like
navigating that side of the equation I'd
love to hear your wisdom on that Evan
because i know you have walked through
many open doors data anyway i'm just
curious but for me it is really i just
want to say to you whatever happened
this is if you do want to get to the
point of reaching your potential the
only real way to do it is to do it
afraid because you know
every person who's ever actually gone
for it whenever it is they had to go
through this process it's so hard but
you have to do it and the other
alternative is what staying in your room
like turning the lights out closing the
door and like being afraid and not doing
anything and you will never be you'll
never be satisfied with that so anyway
just a little bit of encouragement that
this is normal for anyone who is
actually going taking action toward what
their potential is as far as the actual
execution though and then I met pass
that on to you or whatever other wisdom
you will share stop self sabotaging mmm
you've already done the hard work you've
already done the steps that nobody else
wants to do that most people are afraid
to do it done the hardest part of this
whole equation you had this crazy idea
this vision that came to you in a dream
or in a shower wherever you were I'm
gonna go and reach out to this company
yeah how many people have those ideas
tons but then you actually did bring
like that's where most people stop right
there right like oh they don't they
won't want to hear from me or you know I
don't have enough but you did it and
they met you and they liked you and ask
you to come back this is the second
meeting to the third meeting now uh it
looks like they've just been
corresponding and now he's being brought
into like a board room and probably
selling his idea now more yeah at the
actual officer or whatever great you're
in the door just let your let your
awesome to shine through that energy
that you have you have to channel it
back that initial vision that you had
when you were
what are we doing here okay that initial
vision that you had why you thought it
was such a great idea now's the time
that you go and do it you have the
chance it's right here you've already
done the hard work they like you right
you've got on their radar and they want
to hear your message you've done the
hard work now it's just believing in the
message and yes you're doing something
that's uncomfortable that you're not
used to it's easier maybe from a mindset
point of view to send an email instead
of do a pitch in front of a group of
people somebody same ban teemo who st.
ban teemo no way you know I'm upset here
because league of legends decided to to
make this new tee mo skin skin is like
you can you can you can dress up your
character and in different costume
basically right and that's how they make
money league of legends is a free game
but then you could dress up your
character and he has special effects and
says different things and that's how
they you have to pay for that so they
came up with this new team o devil Teemo
or something and now everybody wants to
play Teemo or ban teemo likely team
alone don't touch team out let's do
something else let's let's fix up any of
the other 200 something champions and
let's just let TMO BTW mo anyway we'll
see what happens it's not i'll go back
to Eve um so I got out I got on a rent
because one of my teammates here said
bang team oh please at least I said
please but um yeah so so yes going into
a boardroom might be a little more
uncomfortable than sending an email but
in terms of the work that's been done
you this is the hardest part you've
already done the hardest part o
righteous got banned at all right Jay's
gonna know me and Jays gonna have to go
min let's hope i get my team oh come on
team oh come on through for me yeah hey
last time we did big the team oh we got
a good victory there
um yes so the mental part is a little
bit harder but the actual actions are
way easier they like you they want to
hear from you they're curious to learn
about what you have to say and just just
remember that and some of the things
that helped me when going when going on
stage or doing a new pitch or talking to
a company that you know might be beyond
what I've ever done before for one is
knowing that my intent is positive so
knowing like I'm here to help them like
I'm here because I'm not just trying to
sell them on something i'm here because
whatever this idea is that i have
whatever the presentation i'm going to
give my intention is to help this
company i'm bringing value right and
just knowing that this isn't a scam you
may feel like a fraud that you don't
have all the answers yet but you're
still coming with more than what they
know about whatever this topic is that
you're going to be presenting them and
so knowing that your intent is positive
at least for me helps the second thing
is knowing that that I have value
knowing that there is value in a message
otherwise they wouldn't have invited you
to come and writing like what you have
to say is important you mean I'll have
all the answers you may not be the best
in the world yet at that but you have
some answers and they're curious and so
don't don't deflect your value don't go
in you don't they go into being you know
super cocky and arrogant but also don't
go in you know feeling like oh I'm so
lucky to be here and I don't really know
what I'm doing I'm this big fraud you
have value or those who wouldn't have
invited you in yeah and then 32 you know
to reach this point I'd be thinking
about regret like this could be your
chance you don't want to be 19 looking
back on your life and saying I didn't
take my shot you know I backed out I
didn't prepare hard enough I wasn't
confident enough I miss my shot that's
that's a killer regret is a killer
so those things help me cuz cuz I'll get
something where I thought I want to back
out from that like I'm not I'm not ready
for that you'll come with some become a
smart excuse at least you have the
self-awareness to know that your self
sabotaging that you're not blaming
something else like oh you know I have a
travel schedule you know I have to be
here for that or I don't want to I don't
want to go because there's nobody to
feed my cat or something right now you
can find out you can find the solution
for you've at least identified that you
are you know self sabotaging yourself
here so that's a great step in
self-awareness hmm so good luck those
three things I think would be super
helpful to help me at least help me
through a lot of the big deals that I've
had to go through that I didn't think I
was capable of and I I don't have felt
like a fraud but I definitely had
limiting beliefs as to whether I could
do it or not hmm and Evan for those who
don't have like he's saying I had this
idea but the intimidation around the not
actually being like a corporate himself
a corporation or whatever things he
built he needs to be not a fraud for
those who don't have that other part of
the equation kind of the practical maybe
even experience like how would you
advise them to go into this on a
practical level do you you just kind of
be you or do you try to like you know I
don't know I guess there's some text and
there's like more technical stuff around
having to go before people and
presenting and having the right
materials or its love of love for
someone who'd be worried about that what
would you tell them some someone someone
on the other team is upset that I stole
team oh he's swearing at me in the chat
that I still teva who why you so popular
I'm
happy about this guy's let team will be
under the radar so I could play him
always um I think you know I think the
biggest issue is just mindset like yes
you can go in and know your stuff reg
you need to know what you're going to
say and you can practice and you can you
know prepare your pitch prepare your
slides and you can do it in front of
your friends or your family or your cat
or your your plant just to experience
and you know before I go off and do it
helps like if you're gonna do a
presentation I said that kind of
jokingly but it helps to pretend like
you know that plant is the person that
you're going to be talking to you know
before I go on stage I'll always have
I'll practice my what I'm going to talk
about all usually pace kind of behind
stage or in the hotel room to go through
our I'm going to glue having rituals
help you know I'll almost always have a
frappuccino with me and so like not that
could that rehearsal and preparation in
frappuccino with the habits helps me
realize you know I've done this before
here we go we're doing again even though
this is might be the biggest stage that
I've done it on so those things can help
but it's it's the mindset that's going
to be the biggest we just lost we just
lost our player where did he go we lost
jinx very sad we r for kidz hi who this
seems to be happening to SJ what's
happening here blues players anyway um
you pick swing did you pick swing okay
that's I try I thought he was going
Victor um the mine sits the biggest
thing wha absolutely cuz if you could be
so well prepared you ready you already
look you already are prepared enough you
already have enough that they want to
meet you right you already know what
you're doing you could prepare a little
bit better but it's not that it's not
the last you know half an hour
preparation is going to really make the
difference is all the work that you
already put in its you being who you are
that's what they're attracted when they
want to learn from so you've already
done most of the hard work in
preparation so those things can help but
but the mindset is the biggest one
mindset some more important thing that
if you if you don't have that right if
you go in feeling like you're a fraud
then doesn't matter how well prepared
you are it's not going to shine through
and you'll need to be a company you
don't need to be a giant corporation
they know you're not a giant corporation
right they know you are not a big
company did you go in and say hey I'm
Microsoft I want to talk to you know
they'll they know and they still want to
meet you it's so fun they don't care
right what they care about is the
knowledge that's in your head and if you
don't let that come out then then you've
you failed them and you failed yourself
so though I mean that's that's my take
those three things is where I what
helped me address the mindset and until
I had the right mindset than it didn't
matter about all the other stuff I think
that that to a greater to greater
audience that's almost everybody's story
to like water you know that the open
door idea what else are you not doing
because are you gonna go back Jay okay
yeah what else what other opportunities
are you letting passed by because of
limiting self belief is you feel you're
not good enough in ames you feel like
you're fri
until you fix that feeling then it's
never gonna you're never going to get
there you're never going to you're never
going to get those big opportunities and
I think part of them fixing that feeling
is is walking through the door and then
you experience that you did it and you
actually could do it and then the
confidence comes I think it's like the
fierce its like the fear sometimes
you've got to do it afraid or sometimes
you got to do it even feeling like a
fraud but you'll gain confidence in the
doing and seeing that you actually are
capable you know sometimes it doesn't
come one before the other yep the more
the more you practice the more
confidence you'll have the more you do
you know small steps that gives you the
courage to go and do bigger steps the
yeah just do it the art Williams this a
great video we put up art Williams on
the channel just do it the point though
is like you already have been practicing
you already know that's why you're
getting in the door that's why they want
to meet you so yes you can practice more
you can get more knowledgeable you can
get better a hundred percent but you
already have enough right now I love
that have another good message right I'm
totally scared yeah that's why they want
to meet him you already have enough
right now won't okay well are we're
still playing for four against five so
it's going to be a rough game if this
person's on back
I had another game recently where same
thing happened it was a DC and Thresh
was playing solo and our player Luis
Lucien his wife I dropped out and then
like 20 minutes later comes back is like
sorry guys my wife I dropped out while
we were you know dying because we were
four kids five he's like I'm tethering
from my phone right now to try to make
it work okay well we're gonna do our
best I like it what's the next question
we got let's do it helped so much
burners let us to it alright next
question oh this is a 14 year old I love
it though you're ever in sprin oars
right now I know Elijah is his name dear
Evan first I'd like to thank you for
your amazing YouTube videos they're very
helpful just like you I love
entrepreneurship my dream is to create
an amazing airline to fly the round the
world I love travel my passions for air
travel and airline I always loved going
to the airport and the excitement of
airport I just really I'm sorry Evan
this is that this is a double we've done
week at this one ok sounded familiar
went ok yeah yeah we've done with one so
go back to episode whatever yeah ah yeah
i yeah ok fastest answer ever live
stream good yes yes ok next question
coming from Larry the butcher Larry the
foot married wait is that is a yeah or
you just came up with that no that's for
real that is real prom name like that
okay Larry the butcher the spoon glues
love shenzi said I just watched your
seven things not to do when starting a
business I want to open a butcher shop I
can't not spend money
for opening with the regulations I can't
part time in my garage I'd love to
though okay this is an interesting
question evident because I will if you
follow Evans channel enough you know he
always says that he hates to spend money
before he's proven that he can make
money which I personally also i love
that message i think it is great I think
there are others out there who have said
you know I mean I heard Barbara from
shark tank say that that I don't
remember exactly the details that she
liked the pressure of I think she had a
loan in her first business and so for
her that pressure of knowing she was
going to have to get out of that
situation of debt was part of what drove
her and and motivated her so obviously
there's two sides to that equation but I
so I leaned on Isla I like the idea of
not getting into debt for your business
but are there cases seven which is not
possible to you know have some kind of
investment before starting this is
something that would be interesting to
to learn almost never and definitely not
in this case it's either a 1 lakh of
resourceful pneus so you just have to
think a little more creatively around it
or to a lack of willingness to do the
small things well another player is that
leaving the game so that's it we're
gonna we're going to lose this one looks
like um
so let me let me break both of those
down uh lack of resourceful pneus did
you know he say about butcher right Fred
the butcher yeah was it Fred it's uh
Larry I'm very wonder what I thought
Larry or the thread Larry the butcher
okay uh you know I think about I think
about butchers have been around forever
right I mean it's not some tech company
you're starting which is butchers have
been around forever how did these guys
so you think they all got started with a
ton of capital right like um from what
medieval times yeah right how long do we
had butchers for the caveman nope it's
oh so there's a way right there's
definitely a way um so you know maybe
you don't start with a store maybe you
don't start with the store maybe you
start renting out space somewhere else
maybe you make a joint venture with
someone else who already has it going I
think of bunners which is a super
successful shop here and do we talk
about bynars I think we might have yes
you're good including for your vegan
pastry or something yeah and they
started they started out of a church
basements selling their study right well
that's woody that's what he's saying
that I just read it because it was a
little bit of spelling or not selling
just a sentence is lower because I can't
with regulations for like an official
for sure you cannot open Anna gross like
a garage part-time yeah got it but so
you find another way boom so you're not
going to start in church basements I get
it but there's another way that you
could do it partner up with one of the
farms like who's making these you know
you're buying your your meet somewhere
right help them sell it
start an online version like regulations
are not are not the end its not to be
all and end all right like it's just
things that you have to work around
mm-hmm so why not partner up with one of
those guys and help them sell it
represent them do an online store
something warm right there's always a
way there's always a way so it's either
lack of creativity around it or you just
don't want to do it you think like oh
that's beneath you that's not your
vision it's too small the step it's not
what you want to do but then what's see
what's the alternative the alternative
is nothing you'll turn us to so just
complain blame res blame regulations
like I can't do it because of
regulations is the worst reason ever I'm
ever going to burn re doing some
speaking 200 years and it takes them at
least when I was there six months to get
a business license mm-hmm just for any
business you want to start a company
because they're so bureaucratic six
months to get started just just to get a
license to operate where we can go you
know to the government office and just
we're in business we can do it online
hey hey and so here's this group of
people who are so passionate about
starting a business that they will wait
six months and they're going to do it
and that that's just part of the game
when they're happy doing it mm-hmm and
it's just that mindset that you need as
an entrepreneur that I'm going to find a
way that nobody's gonna stop me that you
know it's not the government's fault
that I'm not able to do this
it's just finding a way so it's either
the lack of resourcefulness the lack of
creativity again or you're just not
willing to do the smaller thing and a
lot of people a lot of people will be
like that like no I don't wanna you know
I want to sell I want to sell t-shirts
and I want to have it you know when I
have my own store i need to retail
location I don't want to start from home
when I want a retail store but you're
not doing anything right now right and
so sitting there this game is basically
over here sitting there um you know in
your in your home just kind of
complaining that you can't start your
t-shirt business is never gonna get you
anywhere boom so if it's not you find
the most creative person you know and
sit down and take them out the coffee
and brainstorm ten ways you could start
this business on a smaller scale love
that form I really find out if the
difference is because you're just not
willing to do it on a smaller scale or
you just don't have the idea of how to
do it mmm there's always a way I'm cold
may not like the way this is away yeah
I'm am thinking right now so some people
just go to the farmers market and get
some really nice cuts of meat from a guy
who stands there with this little
freezer of meat and so you're right
there's lots of ways you could start
your business right now and you don't
have to maybe that's outside the
regulations okay you don't have to live
outside the regulations there's a way to
do it legally I don't know if that guy's
I don't know if that's
legal or not dry no in his but there is
a way farmer yeah yeah there's always a
way it's always a way like just in
general as an entrepreneur to embrace
that mindset that there is always a way
yeah it's a good thing and yes there's
gonna be a lot of roadblocks a lot of
obstacles one hundred percent there's
always a way there's always a way it's
always a way it's always the way it's
always a way oh cool what do you think
we she I agree on a percent and I think
that if I know what it's like to feel
like there is no way but I also know
that that there always is away and so
it's true and I think some of the most
creative ideas come from from you asking
that question sitting down and thinking
it would maybe with someone else
brainstorming 10 ideas I mean amazing
what comes out of what are seemingly
roadblocks I love it well we lost the
game I ended with two kills no deaths I
team basically sat in the base so we got
a report some jinx for leaving the game
well that's got a short day but exciting
what what what message do you want to
leave us on how many questions we got 22
it was a she yeah we got the two but I
felt like they were both very much I
felt like there was a lot of value to
their or so and I'm not sure there's not
anything I can add to that I think I
think what you said was really powerful
so I don't think I want to actually I
it ok well thank you guys for watching
Oh what the heck did i do I did the
wrong thing oops I think I reported you
Jane said of the okay I don't know
probably won't matter I've meant to do
it on this guy okay wait you can't can
we undo that no I don't think so um well
guys have a great friday hope you guys
stop holding yourself back man stop
being afraid of the open doors stop
being afraid of the open doors that's it
continue to believe have an amazing day
I'll see you soon